what's the easternmost point in the u.s.
well it's actually more complicated
question you may think the semblance
would be main sale Rock main to be
specific and if you said this answer
you'd be right but only one way of
looking at the easternmost point this is
only right if you think of the
easternmost point in the United States
as a relative to the United States
itself and looking at the US as only the
50 states the US but you have to
remember the overseas territories of the
u.s. in this case if we include the
territory to the US not including
embassies bases or war cemeteries which
are technically US soil but not US
territories the easternmost point in the
US relative to the mainland United
States would be point you down in the US
Virgin Islands interestingly the
westernmost point in United States
relative to the United States is also
named point Nudell this time in Guam but
that's topic for another time
so these easternmost points are all
talking about East relative to the US
but we must remember that's not really
what East is East is a relative term and
in its true sense it's all about
longitude east essentially means to the
right of the prime meridian line while
west is to the left
so when we look at Alaska which includes
a long line of islands called the
Aleutian Islands we see that what was
west eventually becomes East because
this island chain actually crosses a
hundred and eightieth line of longitude
the exact opposite of the prime meridian
therefore the closest island to the west
the prime meridian submissive puts no
island holds the title of being the
easternmost point in the united states
now this creates a very interesting
paradox where the easternmost point in
the united states is actually west in
terms of direction of travel of the
westernmost point of the United States a
matching yak island by about 30 miles
this is of course assuming that you're
looking at the westernmost and
easternmost points in terms of longitude
now to finish off this creates one more
paradox where Alaska holds the title of
being the northernmost westernmost and
easternmost state all at the same time
you